in the current age of groundbreaking
discoveries and virtualization digital
technology plays a significant role in
the development of human race even after
the strike of a covet pandemic the tech
universe has found ways to keep
economies throughout the world afloat of
late we have witnessed the world
gravitating towards complete
virtualization work that was formally
done physically is now being done from
remote places
besides that the announcements of new
revolutions such as metaverse web 3.0
and industry 4.0 have started impacting
more lives than ever before creating
millions of employment opportunities
however to become a part of these
revolutions owning technical abilities
is a must
and what better way there could be than
having an accredited certification from
top institutions to back to your tech
expertise
furthermore how amazing will it be if
you get these certifications without
paying any bucks from your pocket
that sounds like a fairy tale right but
don't worry this isn't just a fairy deal
with this video we will provide you with
five certifications for free in order to
take your career to the next level in
the end we will also provide you with a
bonus free course for one of the most
sought after technologies of the modern
era at number five we have python for
beginner certification by skillup python
was designed with code readability in
mind and its syntax let programmers
communicate their notations in fewer
lines of code if you are already
familiar with any other programming
language mastering python is no big deal
however if you are a fresher and have no
prior coding knowledge python is the
best programming language to launch your
id journey with this certification
program you can learn basic to advance
concepts of python programming whether
you are a beginner or a pre-acquainted
with programming this course is 10 hours
long and at the end you will get a
strong sense of what future prospects
this programming language has to offer
you will get to know how to become a
full stack developer with python and
common interview questions asked in
python developer interviews
once you finish all available video
resources in the course catalog you will
receive a free certification by skillup
which will definitely add value to your
resume for the upcoming placement season
the salary for an entry-level python
developer ranges around 4 lakh to 12
lakh rupees in india whereas in the
united states of america it ranges from
68 000 to 96 thousand dollars per annum
next up we have at number four business
analytics with excel
business analytics is the domain of
business management that examines an
organization's data and performance to
draw insights and make data driven
decisions companies these days are
constantly on the lookout for expert
business analysts since the quantitative
decisions have proved a magnificent
asset in driving companies revenue to
the roof
basic knowledge of statistics is the
must-have skill to master business
analytics with this certification you
can enhance your knowledge of microsoft
excel the course will cover concepts
such as excel functions pivot tables
slicers scenario management anova macros
vba and hypothesis testing etc this
extensive free program will also
introduce you to the fundamentals of
statistics and power bi software once
you finish the 4r course within 90 days
you will receive free skill up
certification which will entitle you to
work as a business analyst data analyst
or an analytics manager
so if you love dealing with numbers and
have business management abilities then
numerous fascinating employment
opportunities await you at the end of
this program the entry-level business
analyst earns in the range of 3.5 lakh
to 10.5 lakh rupees in india whereas in
united states of america with the same
job role you can earn fifty thousand
dollars to eighty thousand dollars on an
yearly basis at number three we have
cyber security for beginner
certification
working remotely has become the new norm
since the covert pandemic but this comes
with cyber threats with it due to the
remote access to id infrastructure and
the use of collaboration tools on
endpoint devices to prevent cyber
attacks companies need certified cyber
security and networking professionals
with skill ups introduction to cyber
security program you will learn cyber
security fundamentals such as mitigation
security architecture network security
controls risk management wave iod
security testing and business continuity
this curriculum is created specifically
for beginners to acquaint them with the
current cyber security environment as
well as provide them with knowledge of
necessary tools for assessing and
managing security procedures in
information processing systems this
three hour long self-paced training will
help you launch your journey in the
domain of cyber security
so if your interests lie in the realm of
ethical hacking this certification
program is certainly the first step you
should take the average salary for this
domain ranges between 84 000 to 1 lakh
64 000
in the united states of america and 13.7
lakhs to 30 lakh rupees in india per
annum
next we have introduction to project
management certification at number two
project management entails planning and
organizing a company's resources to
complete a certain project or function
it is frequently connected with
engineering healthcare and information
technology all of which involve a
complicated collection of components
that must be processed and integrated in
a certain order to generate a working
product
quality control and assurance are other
important aspects of project management
since the project management positions
are of a senior level mastering the
fundamentals of project management from
a reputable source is quite essential
this free online program is a great way
to go out about it
at the end of this project you will get
hands-on experience with the tool ms
project management 2013 and you can use
it to schedule and manage projects on an
average project manager can make 60 000
dollars per year in the united states
and up to 15 lakh rupees per year in
india
finally we have machine learning
certification at the top of our list
imagine machines making intelligent
decisions like humans as of every sci-fi
movie you have witnessed
how astounding would it be right well
now this is not imaginary thought it has
become very much of a reality the domain
of artificial intelligence and machine
learning has made it a reality with a
ton of efforts in the last few decades
this is why it has become the most
popular carrier in 2022. in the previous
year's trends ai has shown staggering
344 percent growth and the right
certification can help you do wonders in
this great domain however before doing
that you must gain knowledge about the
basics of mathematics statistics and
python programming with this free course
you will get to learn multiple
supervised and unsupervised learning
algorithms along with a few industry
based projects towards the end once you
finish all video resources in this
course you will automatically get free
certification by skiller so what are you
waiting for
visit the killer platform by simply
learn and start exploring different
course catalogs to pick up the best free
certifications for you a machine
learning professional can earn between 5
lakhs to 42 lakh rupees in india whereas
in the united states of america the
salary for this profession ranges
between seventy six thousand dollars to
one hundred and fifty four thousand
dollars per annum
besides these courses we have one more
bonus and training certification you
should look into this skill up
certification covers the hottest
technology these days which has grown
exponentially over the last few years
seeking to virtualize id company
resources according to the idc by the
end of this year the cloud will attain a
growth rate of 22 percent and a value of
277 billion dollars and because of this
there will undoubtedly be a high demand
for cloud experts let's kill up
introduction to cloud computing
certification you can learn about cloud
architecture security services and
hosting at the end of this course
catalog you will get to know more about
what future prospects cloud computing as
a carrier has to offer along with the
case study of building a business case
for cloud
this beginner level accredited program
will help you familiarize with cloud
computing concepts after finishing it
you can apply for aws azure or gcp
examinations for cloud professionals or
you can also choose post graduation
degree program offered by simply learn
to become an industry expert and there
you go that's our list of top 5 free
certifications with that we have reached
the end of this video thank you for
watching the video and i wish you all
the best in launching your free
upskilling journey
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here